it would not have registered with most
Saudis that Saudi Arabia in a very
significant move was included in the g20
top 20 economic powers but it's very
striking when you see the photograph of
g20 meetings there's just one Arab just
one Arab there one King dressed in his
traditional robes and you know Saudi
Arabia is an absolute monarchy but it's
become crucial to the world economy not
just because of its oil but because
actually of all the oil producers it's
the one that's most careful with this
money that's partly because oil is so
inexpensive to produce they make more
profit on it than anyone else but the
Saudi Arabia is now one of the chief
supports of the dollar all their
surpluses just go unquestioningly into
propping up the dollar and were they
ever to withdraw their support from the
dollar the dollar would collapse
Saudi Arabia has a very ambivalent
attitude towards the modern world yes
it's proud to belong to the g20 but at
the same time with the Copenhagen talks
coming up it's sort of putting itself up
I think this is a terrible mistake as a
sort of trade labor union spokesman for
the oil producers saying well if you
developed countries are going to cut
down how much oil you use then you
better pay us some compensation I think
that's very mistaken I mean already the
world has enough difficulty liking Saudi
Arabia I mean how'd you like a country
that you know gets oil out of the ground
for a few dollars a barrel then charges
are seventy dollars for it you know I
mean you know they will explain that
they got a country to run they've got
nothing else they produce but and then
this country gives you terrorists as
well so it's god image problems and I
would have thought it's very ill-advised
of it to complain especially since in
reality it's doing quite a lot to study
alternative forms of energy because they
know it's in their own interests they
are now one of the leading researchers
in the world into solar energy because
they've got a lot of Sun out there and
they're looking into this strange
technology of taking a sort of biomass
slime you put it in the Sun it sucks co2
carbon dioxide out of the air and
creates more biomass sounds sort of dr.
Strangelove and creepy Burt um they're
doing all this sort of thing and I would
have thought they were much better
telling the world about that than trying
to get compensation for the fact that I
mean I think it's going to be a long
time before we ever you know give up
petrol oil in our cars in it it's a very
very for all its polluting qualities
there's just nothing so there's not such
an intense power source that's so
portable and easy to use